newly-elected Utah senator Mitt Romney
kicked off 2019 with an op-ed in the
Washington Post that savaged Donald
Trump's character and leadership
Romney's attack and Trump's response
this morning on Twitter are the latest
salvos in a long-standing personal feud
between the two men it's even possible
that Romney is planning to challenge
Trump for the Republican nomination in
2020 we'll see but for now Romney's
piece is fascinating on its own terms in
well worth reading it's a window into
how the people in charge in both parties
see our country
Romney's main complaint in the piece is
that Donald Trump is a mercurial and
divisive leader that's true of course
but beneath the personal slights Romney
has a policy critique of Trump he seems
genuinely angry that Donald Trump might
pull American troops out of the Syrian
civil war Romney doesn't explain how
staying in Syria would benefit America
he doesn't appear to consider that a
relevant question more policing in the
Middle East is always better
we know that virtually everyone in
Washington agrees corporate tax cuts are
also popular in Washington and Romney is
strongly on board with those to his
peace throws a rare compliment to Trump
for cutting the corporate rate a year
ago that's not surprising Romney spent
the bulk of his business career at a
firm called Bain Capital Bain Capital
all but invented what is now a familiar
business strategy take over an existing
company for a short period of time cut
costs by firing employees run up the
debt extract the wealth and move on
sometimes leaving retirees without their
earned pensions Romney became
fantastically rich doing this meanwhile
a remarkable number of the companies are
now bankrupt or extinct this is the
private equity model a ruling class sees
nothing wrong with it it's how they run
the country
Mitt Romney refers to unwavering support
for a financed based economy and an
internationalist foreign policy as the
mainstream Republican view and he's
right about that
for generations Republicans have
considered it their duty to make the
world safe for banking while
simultaneously prosecuting evermore
foreign wars modern Democrats generally
support those goals enthusiastically
there are signs however that most people
do not support this agenda and not just
here in America
in countries around the world France
Brazil Sweden the Philippines Germany
many others voters suddenly are backing
candidates and ideas that would have
been unimaginable just a decade ago
these are not isolated events what
you're watching is entire populations
revolting against leaders who refuse to
improve their lives something like this
has been happening in our country for
the past three years Donald Trump wrote
a surge of popular discontent all the
way to the White House does he
understand the political revolution that
he harnessed can he reverse the economic
and cultural trends that are destroying
America those are open questions but
they're less relevant than we think at
some point Donald Trump will be gone the
rest of us will be gone too the country
will remain what kind of country will it
be then how do we want our grandchildren
to live those are the only questions
that matter the answer to them used to
be obvious the overriding goal for
America is more prosperity meaning
cheaper consumer goods but is that still
true does anyone still believe that
cheaper iPhones or more Amazon
deliveries of plastic garbage from China
are gonna make us happy they haven't so
far a lot of Americans are drowning in
stuff and yet drug addiction and suicide
are depopulating large parts of the
country anyone who thinks the health of
a nation can be summed up in GDP is an
idiot the goal for America is both
simpler and more elusive than mere
prosperity it's happiness there are a
lot of agree ingredients in being happy
dignity purpose self-control
independence above all deep
relationships with other people those
are the things that you want for your
children
they're what our leaders should want for
us and would want if they cared but our
leaders don't care we are ruled by
mercenaries who feel no long-term
obligation to the people they rule their
day traders substitute teachers they're
just passing through
they have no skin in this game and it
shows they can't solve our problems they
don't even bother to understand our
problems one of the biggest lies our
leaders tell us is that you can separate
economics from everything else that
matters economics is a topic for public
debate family and faith and culture
meanwhile those are personal matters
both parties believe this members of our
educated upper
classes now the backbone of the
Democratic Party usually describe
themselves as fiscally responsible and
socially moderate in other words
functionally libertarian they don't care
how you live as long as the bills are
paid and the markets function some of
they don't see a connection between
people's personal lives and the health
of our economy or for that matter the
country's ability to pay its bills as
far as they're concerned these are two
totally separate categories social
conservatives meanwhile come to the
debate from the opposite perspective and
yet reach a strikingly similar
conclusion the real problem we hear them
say is that the American family is
collapsing nothing can be fixed before
we fix that yet like the libertarians
they claim to oppose many social
conservatives also consider markets
sacrosanct the idea that families are
being crushed by market forces never
seems to occur to them they refuse to
consider it
questioning markets feels like apostasy
both sides in this missed the obvious
point culture and economics are ear
Septon separably intertwined certain
economic systems allow families to
thrive thriving families make market
economies possible you cannot separate
the two
it used to be possible to deny this but
it's not anymore the evidence is now
overwhelming how do we know consider the
inner cities 30 years ago conservatives
looked at Detroit and Newark and many
other places and they were horrified by
what they saw conventional families had
all but disappeared in poor
neighborhoods the majority of children
were born out of wedlock single mothers
were the rule crime and drugs and
disorder became universal what caused
this nightmare
well liberals didn't even want to
acknowledge the question they were
benefiting from the disaster in the form
of reliable votes conservatives though
had an explanation for inner-city
dysfunction and it made sense big
government decades of badly designed
social programs had driven fathers from
the home and created what conservatives
called a culture of poverty that trapped
people and generational decline well
there was truth in this but it wasn't
the whole story how do we know well
because virtually the same thing has
happened decades later to an entirely
different population in many ways rural
America now looks a lot like Detroit
this is striking because rural Americans
wouldn't seem to have very much in
common
with anyone from the inner city the
groups have different cultures different
traditions different political beliefs
usually they have different skin colors
rural people or white conservatives
mostly get the pathologies of modern
rural America are familiar to anyone who
visited downtown Baltimore in the 1980s
stunning out of wedlock birth rates high
male unemployment a terrifying drug
epidemic two different worlds similar
outcomes how did this happen well you'd
think our ruling class would be deeply
interested in knowing the answer but
mostly they're not they don't have to be
interested it's easier to import foreign
labor to take the place of native-born
Americans who are slipping behind but
Republicans now represent rural voters
they ought to be interested and here's a
big part of the answer
male wages declined manufacturing a
male-dominated industry all but
disappeared over the course of a
generation although remained in many
places were the schools and the
hospitals and both of them are
traditional employers of women in many
areas women suddenly made more than men
now before you applaud that as a victory
for feminism consider some of the
effects
study after study has shown that when
men make less than women women generally
don't want to marry them and maybe they
should want to marry them but they don't
over big populations this causes a drop
in marriage a spike and out of wedlock
births and all the familiar disasters
that inevitably follow more drug and
alcohol abuse higher incarceration rates
fewer families form to the next
generation this is not speculation it's
not propaganda from the evangelicals
it's social science we know it's true
rich people know it best of all that's
why they get married before they have
kids that model works but increasingly
marriage is a luxury only the affluent
in America can afford and yet and here's
the bewildering and infuriating part
those very same affluent married people
the ones who make virtually all the
decisions in our society are doing
pretty much nothing to help the people
below them get and stay married rich
people are happy to fight malaria in
Congo but working to raise men's wages
and Dayton or Detroit that's crazy
this is negligence on a massive scale
both parties ignore
the crisis in marriage are mindless
cultural leaders act like it's still
1961 and the biggest problem American
families face is that sexism is
preventing millions of housewives from
becoming investment bankers or Facebook
executives for our ruling class more
investment banking is almost always the
answer they teach us it's more virtuous
to devote your life to some soulless
corporation than it is to raise your own
kids Sheryl Sandberg of Facebook wrote
an entire book about this Sandberg
explained that our first duty is to
shareholders above our own children no
surprise there Sandberg herself is one
of America's biggest shareholders
propaganda like this has made her rich
what's remarkable is how the rest of us
responded to it we didn't question why
Sandberg was saying this we didn't laugh
in her face at the pure absurdity of it
our corporate media celebrated Sheryl
Sandberg as the leader of a liberation
movement her book became a best-seller
lean in as if putting a corporation
first is empowerment it is not it is
bondage and Republicans should say so
they should also speak out against the
ugliest parts of our financial system
not all commerce is good why is it
defensible to loan people money they
can't possibly repay or charge them
interest that impoverishes them payday
loan outlets in poor neighborhoods
collect four hundred percent annual
interest we okay with that we should not
be libertarians tell us that's how
markets work and scenting adults making
voluntary decisions about how to live
their lives okay but it's also
disgusting if you care about America you
ought to oppose the exploitation of
Americans whether it's happening in the
inner city or on Wall Street and by the
way if you really loved your fellow
Americans as our leaders should it would
break your heart to see them high all
the time which they are a huge number of
our kids especially our boys are smoking
weed constantly you may not realize that
because new technology has made it all
but odorless but it's everywhere and
that's not an accident once our leaders
understood they could get rich from
marijuana marijuana became ubiquitous in
many places tax hungry politicians have
legalized or decriminalized it former
Speaker of the House John Boehner now
lobbies for the marijuana industry his
fellow Republicans seemed fine with that
but it's better for you than alcohol
they tell us maybe who cares
talking about missing the point driving
dinner with a 19 year old who's been
smoking weed the life is gone
passive flat trapped in their own heads
do you want that for your kids of course
not
then why are our leaders pushing it on
us you know the reason because they
don't care about us when you care about
people you do your best to treat them
fairly our leaders don't even try they
hand out jobs and contracts and
scholarships and slots at prestigious
universities based purely on how we look
there's nothing less fair than that
though our tax code does come close
under our current system an American who
works for a salary pays about twice the
tax rate as someone who's living off
inherited money it doesn't work at all
we tax capital at half the rate we tax
labor it's a sweet deal if you work in
finance as many of our richest people do
in 2010 for example Mitt Romney made
about 22 million dollars in investment
income he paid an effective federal tax
rate of 14% for normal upper middle
class wage earners the federal tax rate
is nearly 40% no wonder if Mitt Romney
supports the status quo but for everyone
else it's infuriating
our leaders rarely mention any of this
they tell us our multi-tiered tax code
is based on the principles of the free
market
please it's based on laws that the
Congress passed was that companies
lobbied for in order to increase their
economic advantage and it worked well
for those people they did increase your
economic advantage but for everyone else
there was a big cost unfairness is
profoundly divisive when you favor one
child over another your kids don't hate
you they hate each other and that
happens in countries too it's happening
in our country probably by design
divided countries are easier to rule and
nothing divides us like the perception
that some people are getting special
treatment in our country some people
definitely are getting special treatment
Republicans should oppose that with
everything they have so the question is
what kind of country do you want to live
in well a fair country a decent country
a cohesive country a country whose
leaders don't accelerate the forces of
change purely for their own profit and
amusement
a country you might recognize when
you're old a country that listens to
young people who don't live in Brooklyn
a country where you can make a solid
living outside of the big cities a
country where Lewiston Maine seems
almost as important as the west side of
Los Angeles a country where
environmentalism means getting outside
and picking up the trash a clean orderly
stable country that respects itself and
above all a country or normal people
with an average education who grew up no
place special can get married and have
happy kids and repeat unto the
generations a country that actually
cares about families the building block
of everything what would take to get a
country like that leaders who want it
for now those leaders will have to be
Republicans there's no option at this
point
but first Republican leaders will have
to acknowledge that market capitalism is
not a religion market capitalism is a
tool like a staple gun or a toaster
you'd have to be a fool to worship it
our system was created by human beings
for the benefit of human beings we do
not exist to serve markets just the
opposite any economic system that
weakens and destroys families is not
worth having a system like that is the
enemy of a healthy society internalizing
all this will not be easy for Republican
leaders they'll have to unlearn decades
of bumper sticker talking points in
corporate propaganda they'll likely lose
donors in the process they'll be
criticized libertarians are certain to
call any deviation from market
fundamentalism a form of socialism
that's a lie socialism is a disaster it
does not work in fact it's what we
should be working desperately to avoid
but socialism is exactly what we're
going to get and very soon unless a
group of responsible people in our
political system reforms the American
economy in a way that protects normal
people if you want to put America first
you've got to put its families first